and the game of thrones official fan
vention is coming early next year fans
can expect three days of action-packed
events there's going to be panel
discussions photo ops maybe even some
special guests
there will also be exclusive game of
thrones merchandise on sale over at the
rio because that event is going to be
happening next february tickets we're
told will go on sale soon but ted and i
have really been in withdrawals for our
favorite show since it ended back in may
of 2019 so yeah we asked our art
department to come up
with this little beauty
of jon snow and khaleesi
better known
as denise and ted because we really miss
our show we
really do i surprised ted you look good
with a mustache
you know i'm not trying to do that
actually i'm going to try to grow this
is who we should be for halloween yeah
oh seriously though right get in there
say your favorite line my favorite line
from the from the
series but winter is coleman there it is
but our little fingers are there but
brian likes my little finger ready
denise walden's i only have eyes for
sansa stock
that's we're going to stop right that's
ted's hidden talent surprise chad i got
you
you always get me i do yes me every time
come